الانتهاكات هو الاقليميه تحدي الابرز امام
حكومه رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيع
السوداني وهنا يبدو ان اقليم كردستان
العراق بات وحيدا في مواجهه تماديل جارتين
اللتين لم تحافظ على مبدا حصن الجوار
تركيا وايران الدولتان مستمرتان في انتهاك
سياده العراقي بالهجمات والذريعه استهداف
المسلحين الاكراد الانتهاك لم يتوقف عند
هذا الحد بل طال المنافذ الحدوديه غير
الرسميه التي تدشنها السلطات الايرانيه
بين اراضيها واقليم كردستان والانتهاكات
والمستمره رغم ان السوداني اذانها رغم انه
اكد قبلها اهميه الشراكه مع طهران والعمل
معها وهو مرشح الاطار الموالي لايران
الاصلي بالتالي سيكون عليه فعل المزيد
لابعاد الشكوكان تشير الى تدخل الايرانيه
اكبر في شؤون العراق خلال رئاسته للحكومه
استراتيجيه الرد العراقي لوقف الخروقات
الايرانيه المستمره لسيادات العراق
والوقوف بوجه هجمات الحرس الثوري الايراني
على اقليم كردستان العراق مهمته لا تبدو
بالسهله على رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني المدعوم اصلا من ايران
واذرعها السياسيه ببغداد لاسيما وان
السوداني وصل رئاسه الوزراء بدعم المباشره
من القوه الولائيه بالمقابل من الصعب ان
يتخيل العراقيون ان يعمد السوداني الى
مناكفه او اثارتها حفيظه الدول العربيه
مباشره وربما سيعان السودان من حالته من
التجاذبات والاستطبات التي ستعصفه
بالسياسه الداخليه العراقيه وقد تلزمه
اللجوء الى سياسات تسويه ومداهنات
وبالتالي فان استراتيجيه ردعه من قبل
السوداني وحكومته في مواجهه الخروقات
الايرانيه وكذلك تركيا
احتمالاتها ضئيله بحسب مراقبين